In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinoxadeon for June 5, on which we commemorate the Holy New Martyr
Mark of Smyrna.
Born in Smyrna of devout parents, Mark had founded a small business in new Ephesus after having
lived on heels where he married.
But in the act of adultery, with a Christian woman called Maria, they were both taken before
the Aga, who managed to make them apostatize.
Mark entered the Aga's service and knew how to gain his favor by showing great harshness
towards Christians, but deep down remorse tormented him increasingly.
After nine months being able no longer to endure it, Mark finally went to a priest to confess
his sin with tears.
The woman did the same and asked the confessor to find a way to avoid having the child,
which she had from her previous marriage, circumcised.
With the complicity of a doctor, they set sail for Smyrna under the pretext of going
to have Maria treated for a serious illness.
However, shortly after they had left, the Aga, thinking that he might have been tricked,
murdered them, pursued.
The fugitives avoided Smyrna and arrived in the Venetian archipelago, where they were
reconciled with Holy Church by unction with the Holy Chrism, and their marriage was blessed.
This situation did not, though, ease Mark's conscience and going from place to place.
Even as far as Russia, he nowhere found rest and nourished the thought of definitively
washing his double-falth in the blood of martyrdom.
Returning to Ottoman lands he confided his project to various bishops and spiritual fathers,
but they all advised him not to give himself over to death, saying that the path of repentance
was enough.
Nevertheless, the fire of the love of Christ that burned in his heart left him no peace.
Someone made the decision to go and confess his conversion at the place of his fault.
He returned to new Ephesus, where he sought out his first confessor.
The latter did not dissuade him from offering himself for martyrdom, but did advise him not
to do this in new Ephesus, because the Turks had been so ill-disposed towards the Christians
since the recent martyrdom of St. George, and also because of the work of building a new
church, because of which they risked provoking several reprisals against the people.
Mark therefore returned disappointed to Heol's.
Two priests of his acquaintance tried to convince him that this attempt, having failed in spite
of himself, he would not be deprived of the crown of martyrdom by intention, and it would
suffice for him to go and live the ascetic life on Mount Athos.
But none of their arguments succeeded in persuading him.
After having spent the night in prayer and received Holy Communion, he went before the tribunal
as soon as it opened.
Throwing his turban on the ground, putting on an Athenite scufus, and holding across in
his hand, he confessed his conversion.
The judge asked him if he had gone mad or was drunk, but Mark assured him in a clear voice
that he was in possession of all his senses, and that he was ready to endure any suffering
and shed his blood for the love of Christ.
Throne into prison, and his feet put in a vice, he joyously sang hymns and psalms.
The chief guard, incensed, flung into the cell and kicked him thirty times all over
his body.
He said on him, with redoubled rage, when the saint revealed that he was a Christian apostate.
Spitting blood, Mark never stopped thanking God, and was encouraged by the vision of three
new martyrs who called him to join them as quickly as he could.
To the tribunal for a second interrogation, he reiterated his declarations and forcibly
condemned the Muslim religion.
Those present joined with the torturers and beating him unmercifully, but he said to them,
if you knew where I am going, you would drop those cudgles and follow me.
From the beginning of his struggle, the Christians of Heolce began to fast and gather in
the churches to pray for his constancy, and Holy Communion was taking to him every day.
At the end of his third appearance, on the 5th of June, 1801, the judge ordered that they
proceed with his beheading.
Mark hurried to the scaffold where a huge crowd had gathered.
Healing, he offered his neck to the headsmen, saying, strike well.
He, having missed his blow through awkwardness, struck six times before the saint's head,
fell to the ground.
The crowd rushed forward to gather pieces of his clothing, soaked in his blood, while
others went to the churches to offer hymns of thanksgiving.
All the relics gave off a divine fragrance, and they worked many miracles.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.